uh good evening and welcome to this
meeting of the council
i am councillor paul ekpanyong chairman
of mid suffolk district council and i
will be chairing the meeting today
before the meeting commences i would
like to welcome councillor austin davies
ward member for thurston to his first
council meeting
welcome councillor
i'm sure you will all join me to
congratulate him on his recent election
[Applause]
secondly
i'm sure like myself many of you would
have woken up to the news that uh
sadly the russians have invaded ukraine
and
i don't know about all of you but i'm a
very peaceable sort of person and i
think that's a very poor move on the
russian spot
so i'd like you to join me if you would
in
[Music]
basically showing solidarity with our
ukrainian brothers and sisters
[Applause]
thank you
now i'd like to remind you of some
domestic arrangements toilets are
situated outside the meeting room
opposite the stairs cold water is also
available in the breakout area outside
the meeting room
if the fire alarm should sound and we
don't expect you to please leave the
meeting room by the following by
following the fire exit signs and meet
on the ipswich town football club
training pitch
do not re-enter the building until you
are told it is safe to do so
please switch off all mobile phones or
turn them to silent
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting you are also
consenting to being filmed by the
council and to possible use of those
images and sound recordings for
webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph
or broadcast this meeting when the
public and the press are not lawfully
excluded
all right with that i will now move to
the agenda and item one apologies for
absence
thank you chair i have received
apologies for absence from councillor
gould and council phillips
thank you
item two declaration of interest by
councillors
in accordance with the delegated
authority the monitoring officer has
granted dispensations to all members in
respect of the 2223
budget papers
are there any other declarations of
interest
no
thank you
so we will now move to item number three
on the agenda this is paper mc
oblique two one oblique two four
uh someone got a phone thingy
okay
so
item number three then
uh paper mc oblique 21 oblique 24 this
is to confirm the minutes of the meeting
held on the 27th of january 2022
and it's for accuracy only
are there any issues with accuracy
councillor geek
thank you chair yes um
sorry i'm getting so short-sighted i
have to pick my computer up
there was a section in the half-yearly
report on treasury management paragraph
55.8 it says that i gave my opinion that
an investment was likely to get a poor
return and perhaps it should be
rethought this isn't right i didn't give
my opinion i mean those who know me know
that i don't have opinions on such
things i drew members attention to the
opinion of the risk management part of
the officer's report that was on
page 52 of last month's papers paragraph
8.2 where it said that the likelihood of
poor return on investments is probable
so i was drawing attention to somebody
else's opinion not giving my own opinion
and i would be grateful if it could be
changed
we'll take care of that any other points
of accuracy with the minutes
if not can i have a proposal please
come for me and the second please
counselor loving hannigan thank you very
much
i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the vote which will be by a show of
hands so all those in
i favor that's unanimous
thank you all very much
um we will then move to item number four
which is the leaders announcement and i
would like to invite councillor morley
to present her update
[Applause]
good evening councillors
we of course have important matter of
the council's budgets tonight to debate
and so i will be brief
as leader of the council i would also
like to begin by congratulating and
welcoming our newly elected councillor
for thurston councillor austin davis
i had the pleasure of meeting you sorry
molly would you speak up a bit more
no that's about as loud as that's going
to get i'm afraid
i'll start that paragraph again though
as leader of the council i would also
like to begin by congratulating and
welcoming our newly elected councillor
for thurston
councillor austin davis
i had the pleasure of meeting and
welcoming austin at the count last
thursday and i now formally welcome him
to the mid-suffolk district council of
council and our chamber
welcome austin
next i would like to thank all of you
our staff and the wider emergency
services who rose to the challenge of
the succession of storms last week
fortunately we're not as badly affected
by those storms and related flooding as
some other parts of the uk
but the impact was still felt by many of
our residents
i was one of them as were several other
councillors having lost power for 24
hours and overnight into saturday
our teams helped fight the elements to
ensure our residents were supported and
kept safe
this included a bid building services
team who provided emergency cover
helping our tenants in need on friday
and over the weekend
and our public realm team
who created two rapid response teams
with officers out and about dealing with
fallen trees
thank you also to all of our officers
that responded to our request to provide
emergency support over the weekend
there were more volunteers than required
and your selfishness selflessness
and flexibility is truly appreciated
thank you
this week of course we have had the
government's announcement about the
listing lifting of remaining covered
restrictions
we already had a draft transition plan
in place that is being reviewed in light
of the government's announcements
this plan means that all of our existing
internal arrangements will remain in
place for now
but that we will be safely moving to
more
normal working
councillors may also have seen that on
friday last week judgment was handed
down in relation
to thurston parish council's judicial
review of our planning committee's
decision
officers are currently reviewing the
judgment and considering next steps
so there is nothing further i can add on
this tonight
but there will of course be further
engagement with planning committee
members shortly
sticking with the theme of planning i
know councillors have been awaiting the
outcome of the planning peer review that
took place before christmas
the draft report from the planning
advisory service was unfortunately
delayed due to covered related ill
health
we have however now received this report
which has been fact checked by officers
i am pleased that discussions of the
recommendations and the development of a
relevant action plan can therefore begin
shortly
as always councillors will have directly
received and seen the various press
reports that have been published by the
council since we last met
all of which are also available on our
website
i will therefore not spend time
repeating them all here tonight
but as it is currently half term for our
schools i did want to mention how proud
i am of the activities we have on offer
for our younger residents of mid-suffolk
including football swimming crafts and
outdoor cooking
similarly i did also want to say how
pleased and proud i am to see the
opening of the new library in needham
market and the nine new affordable homes
in bottasdale
these nine affordable rent homes are
made up of two and three-bedroom houses
a two-bedroom bungalow and four
one-bedroom flats
with air source heat pumps installed as
the primary heating source in the houses
and electric heating system in the
apartments
we are literally building great
communities with bright and healthy
futures that everyone can be proud to
call home and i couldn't be more excited
about it
finally and sticking with the theme of
exciting opportunities
you will all have seen that suffolk
was successfully named as one of the
nine pathfinder county deals in the
leveling up white paper
this success came following two
delegations with white tor
led by councillor hicks as leader of the
county council and by me as chairman of
the suffolk public sector leaders
unlike in other parts of our county we
are and will continue to all work
together collectively between the
district borough and county councils
to secure the best possible deal for the
residents and communities of suffolk
it is early days in these discussions
with government but there is an
ambitious timetable to include to agree
deals by the end of the summer so i will
continue to keep you as engaged as i can
in this process
thank you
thank you councillor molly
okay i guess there are no points of
clarification we'll move on to
counselor melon
so
you are seeking a point of clarification
yeah thank you chair um
thank you uh councillor morley for uh
for those words i just had a quick query
on one
uh point that you mentioned which is the
judicial review um in thurston since
there's a potential award for costs
against the council
arising from this case has the scale of
those costs been included
on our risk register
as i said
we are looking at those
items and
i have nothing further to add at this
time
so we move on to item number five and
that is to receive the notification of
petitions in accordance with council
produ procedure rules
thank you chair non-received
all right and we'll move to item six and
this is relating to questions by the
public in accordance with council
procedurals
non-received chair thank you
and so we'll move on to item number
seven
questions by councillors in accordance
with council procedure rules
i refer you to the question in the table
papers i would like to invite councillor
mellon to ask his question
thank you chair um my question is uh i
believe it's for councillor brewster
when will the future use of the former
nat west building natwest bank building
in stone market be confirmed thank you
chad
question councilman mellon
the council have agreed key terms with
the john peel center for a new release
and each party's lawyers are working on
fine final matters which are likely to
be concluded within uh four to six weeks
and alongside the lease negotiations the
council has previously agreed to fund
repairs to the roof and we have
appointed a consultant to carry out a
final assessment and prepare attend a
specification for the work
it is likely that the work will be
tended within the next two to three
weeks
and works will commence once a
contractor is appointed
thank you councillor brewster uh
councillor mellon would you like to ask
a supplementary question
please go ahead
i would chair thank you um
can i just say how that i am to see
councillor barista back on his feet
after his recent illness
um i'm sure we all welcome that but i do
have a supplementary question um
councillor brewster was featured in the
east anglian daily times in march 2019
um
saying that this this vacant building at
the heart of the town
um will enjoy a new lease of life and
give local residents a new and exciting
community space
in the heart of the town
um so my question is really why has it
taken three years to get from that point
to this point thank you chair
councillor brewster would you like to
respond
negotiation going on
uh and and the lease is the one thing
that really held it up and we'll be
holding it up i suppose in the future
but uh
um but yeah if if two people two groups
can work together then i think that
speeds things up
thank you councillors uh we will now
move to item number eight on the agenda
this is paper mc oblique two one oblique
two five
overview and scrutiny committee report
i would like to invite counselor william
to introduce paper mc oblique 21 oblique
25 which is for noting
councillor
thank you chair um i don't intend to be
very long because i think the meeting is
going to be long enough anyway uh just a
couple of points i'd like to get your
members attention too
you'll have noted on page seven at uh
1.2 that a more strategic approach to
scrutiny of budget preparation is
planned for future years
also that the concern there was a
concern that some aspects of financial
scrutiny
may be falling through any gap between
the role of scrutiny and the role of
audit this has been looked at by the
monitoring officer
and the constitution working group
in respect of the hra budget scrutiny
members felt that further information to
enable benchmarking
against other authorities will be useful
for future scrutiny
the committee also resolved that the
number of tenants in receipt of rent
rebate should be given to assist members
consideration of council rents
for
2022-23 so
perhaps
this will be covered by councillor
whitehead in his presentation of the
budget
uh you'll also see that
suffolk overview scrutiny committee
debated the calling of a decision by
cabinet in respect of the taxi licensing
policy committee resolved to refer the
matter back to cabinet for
reconsideration
page 11 of the papers lists the the
observations to be considered by cabinet
when they next debate the policy
i'm happy to try to answer any questions
on the report thank you chair
thank you councillor willem are there
any questions for councillor wellam
okay uh councillor scarf
thank you chair um i know what uh
councillor williams said about the
financial scrutiny in the appropriate
way between the two committees um but
the recommendation was that the
monitoring officer and constitution
re-working group actually look into this
we're five weeks down the line i'm a
member of the constitution working group
i wonder if we can have an update as to
when a meeting would actually be called
so that we can start looking at that
process fairly quickly please
counselor i haven't heard any time scout
for it i'm afraid um i'm i'm looking
about to see if the monetary officer is
here or or if um the chief executive can
can give any view on the time scale
yeah um
chair i'm not aware emily's not here
this week but we will um i'll send her a
note to make sure that um that's on her
work plan
counselor eben
thank you very much chair and thank you
councillor welland for that um in
scrutiny's deliberations with regards to
the
timing of scrutiny of the budget um has
the ons committee the overview and
scrutiny committee considered a budget
process that will include community
consultation in the budget setting of
the budget thank you
council willem
yes it was mentioned during the debate
uh at the time
is
[Laughter]
indeed uh counselor guthrie
yes thank you i'm actually speaking on
behalf of um uh councillor fleming
because she has a voice that's not um
too secure would that be correct
so these are her words is the new
statutory taxi and private hire vehicle
standards which local authorities will
be expected to implement are designed to
improve consistency in the licensing
system
reducing the risk of harm posed to
children and vulnerable passengers
given that the standards have been set
directly to address the safeguarding of
the public and the potential impact of
failings in this area the importance of
thoroughly considering these standards
cannot be overstated
it is not a question of box ticking the
standards must be considered rigorously
and with an open mind
new standards to improve safety for taxi
and private hire
i'm sorry councillor have you got a
question oh i thought you said i could
read this no no
well we're only allowing questions at
this point oh i beg your pardon sorry oh
i'm ahead of yourself i was given the
nod and the nod is not appropriate
the question is may i speak later on
behalf of councillor fleming
i think only only if you have a question
no later oh right yes
okay so um are there any other questions
for councillor welland
okay councillor william do you have
anything else to add to your report
i know nothing else to add thank you
very much
that
members that report was for noting only
so we are now going to move to item
number nine
item number nine here are
recommendations from cabinet stroke
committees so
it is my intention to allow up to two
questions we have a very big
agenda today so it is my intention to
allow up to two questions per counsellor
and allow up to a maximum
in total
a period of 30 minutes for questions for
each of the committee reports that we're
going to consider this evening
so please bear that in mind when we come
to
question and discuss those papers as we
move forward
we'll then now move then to uh item 9a
this is paper mc
oblique 2-1 oblique 2-6
counselor guthrie could
thank you
so this is uh just to start again uh mc
oblique 2-1 oblique 2-6
the general fund budget for 2021
and stroke 2 and 4
year outlook
i would like
so
as this budget reports are complex items
i am minded to allow the proposal of the
report and the proposal of the amendment
up to 10 minutes to introduce their
items
please note that the deadline for
submitting amendments to the budget
papers has passed
and there can be no further amendments
submitted
during the course of this evening
i would like to invite council whitehead
to introduce paper mc321 oblique26 and
to move the recommendations in the
report councillor whitehead
thank you chairman
it's a real honor and privilege to
present my seventh consecutive
mid-suffolk general fund budget to full
council
now over these years we've delivered our
turn significantly ahead of budget and
whilst one driver of that has always
been additional income we should also
acknowledge that in building up the
budget
department by department we've perhaps
laid caution onto caution
so if this new budget 2223 manager has
been pushed to use stretching but
realistic assumptions across both income
and expenditure
we should therefore anticipate going
forward and overall out term position
being close to budget
time will tell
as well as setting the annual budget we
do our best to forecast a four-year
outlook so that we can bring a
longer-term approach to align our
financial strategy to our medium-term
six corporate strategic priorities
now we're not helped in this approach by
central government who for the third
year have provided only one year of
certainty in their local government
settlement
budget preparation starts in the summer
and by mid december
most of the hard graph behind our budget
work
has already been completed
and then just before the christmas break
we have finally told
our local government settlement and
surprise for the budget suddenly there
was an additional 971 000 of income
compared to what we might have
reasonably expected
clearly it's
church not to welcome this money
but
almost invariably we must first put that
money additional money
into
our reserves before any new detail
spending plans can be established
chart 4 in the report of paragraphs 4.27
show the government grant allocation is
749 000 higher
in 2223 compared to 2122
and that includes a very generous new
homes bonus now although not included in
this budget we are now drawing up some
exciting spending plans for this
additional money
more more on that in a minute or two
we are faced with uncertainties beyond
2023 we still don't know
how the government's waste reforms which
we largely support will be funded
we still don't know how or when business
rates will be reformed although we feel
it is inevitable
this doubt there isn't doubtless need
changing because accelerated by the
pandemic
but any reforms could have a dramatic
impact on our finance
as the government has moved away from
its previous idea of 100 retention by
local government
of course we still don't know about the
new homes bonus replacement
so these are just three major examples
that demonstrate the uncertainty and the
voluntary
volatility of the environment in which
we operate
but
despite all that
have increased confidence in our
financial situation
even with such levels of uncertainty and
risk that's just how strong
a financial position we have been able
to create
now last year we had something of a
windfall of income in terms of surplus
funds that had not been budgeted for
we were able to utilize that windfall
topped up by other budgeted reserves to
invest 5.1 million directly back into
our communities that investment will be
spent over this and next year
as a further sign of our confidence we
will not be increasing council tax this
year
we will be freezing our share of council
tax
and due to the current higher rates of
inflation this doesn't represent a
significant real term cut
the growth in our castle tax base rate
as a result of new housing means that
our total council tax collection will
still grow by 4.47 percent
now when i introduced my first budget
seven years ago i hardly dared dream
that seven years later our cast will be
in such a strong financial position
robust reserves very healthy future
projections and the opportunity to now
freeze our share of council tax despite
this uptick in inflation
i have a sincere desire that such a
freeze can be extended beyond this one
year but we will see
the idea seven years ago that we'd be in
such a position to now freeze council
tax yet still be able to put aside over
five million pounds for an array of
special projects
as we emerge from a covid pandemic would
have seemed surreal
a sort of financial science fiction
but we can
and we are
on top of that
we even have such a surprise in store
that our opposition can dare to venture
their own amendment to use 820 000 from
the growth efficiency fund on an
electric bus project which is clearly
close to their heart
i said earlier that we're in the press
of drawing up our own exciting spending
plans for the near one million pounds of
extra money that's come from the local
government settlement
we want to bring these to cabinets at
the earliest opportunity as fully
fledged and deliverable initiatives
we want to really help those residents
that are struggling the most
so i'll just give you a brief flavor we
intend to uplift our regular communities
grants
we'll significantly increase our council
or local
grant look at locality grants
our officers are already investigating
investigating how we can help our local
food banks with financial and other
support
and officers are also looking into how
we could provide free
means-tested epc service
for energy inefficient properties in our
district
so there's that's exciting further use
for our growth and efficiency fund which
is not included in the budget report for
us today
but the plans for which are being worked
on now so reports can come to cabinet as
soon as possible
so we truly have
ambitious plans
which are only made possible by our
financial strength and the hard work
we've put in over the years to get us to
our current position
as always i must acknowledge all the
excellent work of our finance team they
are truly the best
and at this time i want to particularly
thank catherine steele
our soon to be retiring section 151
officer
it really has been a joy and pleasure to
work with her over these many years
her contribution to mississippi district
council has been immense thank you
catherine
[Applause]
so i'd like to now move the
recommendation to approve this general
fund budget for 2223 with its freezing
of our bandy council tax i would ask for
a seconder thank you chairman
[Applause]
thank you councillor whitehead could i
have a second to please
councillor morley
thank you chair i would like to second
and i reserve my right to speak native
thank you councillor
i would now like to invite councillor
field to propose the amendment from the
green and liberal democrat group council
field
thank you
yes uh
seven years a long time
i didn't realize it has gone that far
however
uh you you'll find uh our amendment
detailed in item 9a it has
the figures there and a number of
bullet points but i will
talk about it a little
um obviously our in hope is to uh assist
you with your problem surplus and help
you dispose of
a substantial sum a single large idea
rather than has been perhaps our
tendency in the past to
produce a number of smaller ideas
which frequently are not adopted
so this amendment seeks to address the
transport problems experienced by
segments of our population who can no
longer drive
have never learned to drive are
temporarily unable to drive are unable
to afford a car who or who choose
to use it not to use a private car to
limit their contribution to climate
change
it proposes that mid-suffolk provide but
retain ownership of two small buses and
the necessary rapid charging
infrastructure to using scheduled
services by a community service provider
routes will be chosen so they do not
compete with existing providers
by addressing these needs the council
would spend are not insignificant but
manageable because it had been the
service we have
amount of our budget
it would achieve very significant but
perhaps less measurable benefits to the
economy
it would help the numbers of residents
who constantly ask us
why the bus stops recently installed
never been used
emissions from transport form a large
percentage of the uk total
and to limit climate change we must
reduce these
a return to greater use of public
transport and the tradition a transition
to zero carbon transport in the form of
battery powered electric vehicles is
essential
currently our rural population has
little option but to use private cars
petrol or diesel powered but with a
rapidly growing portion of electric
vehicles
public transport is sparse with few and
infrequent service
in proposing this amendment we are
critically aware that the needs of
mid-suffolk's largely rural population
are less easy to solve than those in an
urban setting
our aging population finds the need to
get to shops
medical financial sup
support and leisure facilities that
boost their health
challenging and in extreme
those most in need tend to be less able
to use internet services as an
alternative to physical travel
our proposal will provide two zero
emission minibuses to operate a defined
scheduled service on a network of routes
to link communities together to service
critical locations
it's vital that the service is
understandable and therefore used by the
target
clientele we should establish scheduled
low-cost perhaps 2.50 a trip or free
services to complement and enhance
demand responsive services provided by
suppliers such as bs evc
we're proposing that the council should
work with a county
and bs
evc or another appropriate operator to
operate and established a service
similar to but more extensive than the
county's catch service
which operates in the county ash area
knowledge should be drawn from that
service and other established community
bus services to ensure that accurate
cost estimates and effective service
parameters can be established
i would ask you to support the amendment
and improve access to a range of
services and activities for a challenge
section of our population in a way which
is fully compatible
with suffix zero carbon environmental
conditions thank you
can i have a second please
councillor eben
thank you chair i'll be very happy to
second this um budget amendment and i'd
like to reserve my
right to speak thank you very much
yes
i may say
just a few words i thank the opposition
for their proposal this year as council
field has explained
it clearly isn't an alternate budget but
as a suggested addition to the table
budget so i am prepared to accept the
opposition amendment i'm happy to ask
officers to drop a detailed viability
plan setting out the business and social
value for this project for cabinet
evaluation
our offices have an excellent track
record in obtaining grants and or match
funding for projects such as this so i'm
sure they would relish the opportunity
to reduce our own outlay on the project
the accountant in me tells me that
capital items can sometimes be better
leased rather than purchased so further
investigation of that aspect is also
clearly needed
so in accepting this amendment i do so
in the hope that the opposition will
support the budget and not vote it down
because if they doubt go on to vote down
the budget their main achievement this
evening will have been the creation of
the shortest lived electric bus project
in history thank you
thank thank you councillor whitehead
right councillors so uh given that uh
that amendment
oh hang on
oh sorry i need to ask councillor molly
whether she also accepts the amendment
my apologies councilor morley
thank you yes i do accept that
thank you so much
right
okay um right so given that um the
amendment has been accepted and given
that
the budget papers have uh been through
ons uh overview and scrutiny
various other committees
group briefings and and the like i would
like to
consider that we move directly to debate
so we have much more time for that
process
so who would like to kick off the debate
councillor amarosa
i beg your pardon
will there be questions
hello sorry council yes i've understood
you i've understood your question yet
the answer is yes
but we're going to move to debate at
this point
who would like to kick off the debate
councillor password
are you doing sorry tim can we clarify
is this questions or debate are we doing
debate in the questions
if i could help you i think the chairman
is telling you both at the same time so
that rather than doing questions and
then move on to debate
anticipating fewer questions i think is
what generally indeed but if there are
questions then obviously if you can
indicate because what we don't want to
do
is give it give an opportunity for
people to miss
their debating slot but okay
that's not a problem thank you arthur so
i've got a bit of a hybrid job in the
first mid suffix so now one of the
serious points on this um and i know it
mentions about inflation in the report
and that's very very important bearing
in mind the uh
i think appalling approach of russian
and and
putin and his regime
invading the ukraine i haven't got
up-to-date figures but i do know
mid-afternoon the price of various raw
materials has shot up
um and it's not just about um
gas and oil if you look at the um
dependency there is for the whole world
for example on they are the biggest
exporter of wheat um precious metals
such as titanium palladium
and other sorts of things i'm just
concerned i think it's a very very good
um budget paper i'm more than happy with
the amendment i just really wanted to
pose the point that um while some people
may have looked at reducing council tax
nevertheless if you look at the
inflationary pressures that are likely
to be well above what is put in this
paper i would just hope that our
financial guru um councillor whitehead
um
is actually confident there is enough in
the system there to counter the extra
inflationary threat threat that we get
because no doubt that will feed through
not just the building materials
supplies logistics wage rises of course
if inflation does indeed get up to the
levels that some of us remember from
many years ago into double digits
we're going to have one hell of a
problem and that will affect all public
services
just as well as everybody else so i'm
right behind this budget i think it's a
very good document welcome the amendment
um i don't know if there's any chance of
reassurance that we have enough in the
system to counter with that renewed
threat thank you
thank you councillor passmore um
councillor ammar rosen
thank you chair
uh i was interested in uh councillor
whitehead's
comment when
accepting the amendment
and his doubt as to whether
our side of the council would would be
voting for the
budget and i was wondering why is why is
there a doubt still
uh in his mind that we might do that so
i'm just wondering kind of cheekily
what are you hiding i'm suspicious
thank you councillor uh councillor
autumn
oh right councillor often can i can i
ask you to wait while councillor
whitehead responds to those two
councillor whitehead thank you if i may
um
the council password didn't actually
point out that all my investments are
shooting down at the moment where
whereas everything else needs to be
shooting up but um to answer the
question is there enough in the system
given the inflation pressures and
certainly there is a big worry about
inflation there's no doubt even before
the
ukraine crisis kicked off but um
my four-year projections despite the
uncertainty that i outlined in my speech
there is such a surplus there already
that i feel there is more than adequate
cushion
we will shortly see in the q3
out turn for this year and that too will
have a
a very healthy surplus compared to
budget so all in all i'm happy that um
we've got enough in the system to cope
for that
um to the point of counsel morrison
the reason i just
the reason i might have had a doubt i
think is just based on the track record
of being in council here for 10 years
and
i can't remember ever having a unanimous
budget and often um historically it's
even gone down to chairman's vote so i
perhaps i'm being a bit cynical and
hopefully
this is a whole new future of
council loving and i look forward to
having unanimous vote on our budget
thank
thank
you
thank you councillor uh councillor
autumn
um yes i would just like to
re reiterate what cancer passmore said i
mean obviously the budget you've got
here in front of us
is the financial situation that we have
at the moment and obviously a lot
has happened in 24 hours
so i'd be interested to know at what
stage
the
administration will be looking at
whether or not some of them quite
drastic changes that have happened in
these 24 hours you will be able to
reconsider your budget as it stands
today i mean 100 pounds for goat you
know for for oil etc it's going to be
phenomenal and it's also going to affect
a lot of our residents
and just a very small item on your
budget i was quite surprised that
considering you are proposing a um a nil
increase in council tax you are
proposing to put up the cost of the
green waste scheme
which i thought we were trying to
encourage people to use that so i would
have thought under the current
circumstances and the financial
situation that was something you could
have managed to
not do this year
thank you
um yeah i mean if our budget was pretty
close to break even rather than having
the service it does have then i would be
more concerned um i think i was reading
recently in the east england daily times
where council of mellon was perhaps even
suggesting we should have reduced
council tax and uh well i mean that as a
conservative that was sort of music to
my own ears but uh i think given all the
uncertainties particularly in since the
last 24 hours to to move perhaps from
even thinking about reducing it to
to keeping it level you know is sensible
um the green waste scheme do you mean
the brown the garden bins yeah i mean my
understanding of that is that the
government in the years time
want to make that a free
service
and
we would lose like 800 000 pounds of
income or something if that happened but
i believe the government
for all councils
will if they
force us to make it a free service they
will reimburse us
you know what our losses are so in some
ways the more we charge now the bigger
the figure that they'll reimburse us for
for years ahead as we follow that it's
so that's it's it's just you know one
year's increase might put a little bit
more money in the pot and then going
forward if the government forces to do
as a free service
where our residents will benefit and
we'll benefit from the more income
that's my
thinking behind it
counselor matheson
thank you chair um
yes well um it would be a pit if we
didn't criticize anything at all
obviously i'd be disappointed for
councillor whitehead
um
so
really i think to some extent these are
points for the chief executives as much
as councillor whitehead and i'm sure he
will speak to the chief accordingly
um
yeah on the on the the terrible war the
point was made very well yesterday
already um
that the you know
our dependency on on petrol on gas on
oil
um is what funds the russians buying
their weapons fundamentally um which is
you know i mean i'm talking about just
britain but more widely so
and i think that's
you know that tells us to redouble our
efforts to move forward as fast as we
can on renewable energy instead of
climate change um fossil fuel
and um just turning more to the detail
um of the the
the congratulation or the
self-congratulation which
this side of the house does have a bit
of a
a concern that the each year's surplus
does arrive
arise from from under delivery of some
things and just to mention a couple of
them really that are the public's
priorities that we all keep hearing
about uh fairly regularly anyway which
is to say planning enforcement can we do
more
um do we need more people to do more
um secondly tree preservation orders um
i'm told i can't get them um can we you
know can we please redouble our
resources
and you know with a greater ability to
actually um
pass and put in place more protection of
more trees
and thirdly obviously um we don't look
as if we put enough resources in over
the last um
what is it five years i can't remember
now getting the joint local plan done um
it's had another unfortunate setback but
i think that the uh you know it should
have been all done and dusted two or
three years ago frankly so if we can put
more
resources into
those public priorities
then i think that's that's better and
it's under delivery
you know as much as good work thank you
councillor stringer
you chair uh as everyone seems to be
making comments about the ukraine before
they start i'm going to make one uh
i find it completely objectionable that
an orange-haired ex-president fool has
come out today praising vladimir putin's
invasion of ukraine as a quote genius
move
i think what will get us through
these current you know very worrying
times is truth and integrity
and i find neither of those in the
comments of that gentleman
and i think we deserve truth and
integrity across this house i think we
have an element of it and i think we can
do with more of it frankly
i'm very surprised that councillor
whitehead
is
so
surprised
that
some on this side of the house are
voting for the budget
we've done that twice in seven years
already
if you go and look back through the
records
a majority of this side has voted for
the administration's budget twice in
seven years
because we agreed with elements that
were in that budget and there were
things that were close to our heart that
we wanted to get over the line so we did
it we've worked with you that's not a
surprise that's what we do
twice
out of seven that's fine
now this is likely to be a third time in
seven years
thank you for that
uh
but of course a budget is only some
lines on a piece of paper
unless you actually deliver it
and that's where the biggest concern is
for for this side of the house
of actually doing each year what we say
we're going to do and actually deliver
on those
estimates of cost and actually deliver
on those services and those wishes that
we want to
help our community be better than it
otherwise would
that side of the equation
is at times found wanting i don't find
it reassuring that year on year we put
more and more back into reserves i find
that slightly worrying
it's worrying is that in the does it
mean our budgets are then realistic yes
other outrageous fortune may help us
with our finances but i remember
some other people are in the same room
over seven years ago when we were given
something called the graph of doom
that that clearly showed how our council
was going to be bankrupt in a few years
and on this side of the house we said no
no no no governments are highly unlikely
to not incentivize house building
and actually that's proved to be quite
true and we've said it every year i
think for about eight years now and that
has been born through yes they could
take it away tomorrow but they don't and
they haven't
and what we should have done with quite
a lot of that money was actually
rocket fuel our communities because the
talent and wit that's out there among
our communities is absolutely phenomenal
i've seen it rise together this weekend
when we've had a number of people in a
village near us that uh had their power
out and it was out for four days
on the second day the village hall was
open because it did have power and there
are people in there cooking meals for
those people charging their phones and
making sure they could send the emails
that they just really want to do
that's what an inspired and
well-connected community can do can you
imagine what it can do if it had a
little bit more funding it could have
had the solar panels on that village
hall and the battery storage which meant
it could have still done that if that
had a power cut as well so there's that
element
we've got sorry we've got brilliant
communities out there
we i will be supporting your budget this
time because you've listened to this
site but we will be watching like a hawk
to make sure you deliver thank you chair
thank you councillor uh call on
councillor ebern
thank you very much chair um and thank
you
councillor whitehead for your comments
um just a couple of quick points is that
um
looking at the the buses one example
that we have got councilwhitehead is the
freighters waste freighters where so you
know there could be a similar situation
where you use that as a business model
as it were where you're purchasing the
best and then
um contract out the actual service
and as others have said
you know we'd want to see it see actual
achievement it actually happening
this year
so we really do need to see that happen
and i think um
just a few comments that um i'd like to
make if i may and i that you know i i
will be supporting it but it depends on
comments that are yet to be made from um
my friends and colleagues opposite
because i've yet i may be still put off
um so um
just just um you know be be wary of
comments you might wish to make
um
but firstly if i may i'd like to also
echo councillor whitehead's um comments
about the officers and particularly
about um catherine steele if i may
mention you by name um and i did comment
that i'm
surprised she's not got the party
poppers in for um
tonight as the um last budget um
before she retires but i would like to
just say
great appreciation to everything that
you've done and your openness to us
to also all i think in any kind of
questions and things is much appreciated
um and as well to
the rest of the team
and i just want to say that when we put
forward um proposals and ideas at this
point in time it's no reflection at all
on the offices we we are wanting to put
forward our group's ideas we aren't
saying in any way whatsoever that we
think that the work that officers is
doing is in any way wrong or whatever we
would just want to
to say this is where we want to be
heading what we want to be to be doing
so i just want to make that clear
i think with regards to a few points
on the budget itself
i'm disappointed really that there's
there's not something in there about
giving a council tax break
it's a one-off for um households in um
dire straits at the moment given the
kind of rising energy costs i know
several members of you know
all our colleagues have mentioned that
so far but i think that would have been
good to see
i also um
i'm concerned about
in the report it talks about stretching
and asking corporate managers to achieve
to
to do more but it seems to be saying to
do more and get more income in as
opposed to achieving more for our
residents and what we want to see is
more achieved you know we want to see
more achieved for our residents for our
communities that we all are part of as
well as serve
and i think
i am still concerned that we are
um
running this high surplus and we are not
spending it we haven't spent the four
million from last year which has gone up
to 5 million we've got another 3.4
million in the pot so i'd really
like to see that spent um in this
financial year and just actually
do what we can and please involve us we
have ideas and we're happy to put them
forward
but we would like to see that funding
spent it's not our money it's our
communities and we need to be spending
it for them to improve their their lives
thank you chair
thank you councillor uh councillor
manson
uh thank you chair i i don't want to uh
reiterate um much of what councilory
burns just said but i do um share her
views um
completely really uh and i but i'd just
like to say that that that isn't it
lovely that we're in such a financially
strong position and and is that is that
just fortuitous or is it
by a
you know by a plan um
you know we have underspent um several
times in the last uh seven years
um every time maybe in the last seven
years and um please um please excuse me
if i misremembered but i was under the
impression that the 4 million or was it
5.1 million that was agreed uh this time
last year i was certainly under the
impression that that was to be spent
during the financial year 21-22 but here
we are today being told that it will be
spent between 22 and 24
and and we're adding yet more to our
reserve budget so um you know
you know i i agree with with uh with
councillor ebon and i was going to say
it's it's uh it's it's lovely to hear
that we're trying to ask our corporate
managers to be ambitious
um about their income and expenditure
but what we really want them to be is to
be ambitious in their delivery um so
that we do get the services um
that we've delivered and i and i and i
also heard councillor whitehead say that
there were lots of plans that would be
worked on and be uh going to cabinet in
the next few months
and i really welcome to hear what those
plans are to spend the money and i just
hope that it is not more jam tomorrow
thank you
thank you councillor uh councillor scott
thank you chair yeah well i'm going to
be voting for the budget no surprise
there um but i would like to point out
um we pointed out at the scrutiny
committee um there were some significant
carry forwards um there's i think 583
000 just on housing
and we did have some concern that that
might not be spent this year so that is
one thing i think that we will be uh
watching
um one thing that hasn't really been
mentioned so far is the average staff
vacancy rate and this was drilled into
by the scrutiny committee at some length
i think the last quarter performance
report said it was 17
scrutiny committee i think we were told
it was an average of nine percent when
we asked what was the average we now
know it's an average of 12 percent
so to be ambitious and to deliver
services on behalf of our residents in
mid-south we do actually need to keep a
very very keen eye on ensuring that we
actually have the staff to be able to
fulfill those promises because without
those staff we're not going to deliver
any of the schemes perhaps there is a
potential there that we fail yet again
so i think that's something that i would
ask that we look at very very carefully
throughout the year i know councillor
whitehead took that on
at scrutiny committee and that is
something we'll certainly be looking at
in councillor whitehead's comments
he talked about the potential perhaps
for securing grant funding towards the
uh bus scheme well that would be great
because if we did secure grant funding
to the bus scheme we could actually go
further we could provide more services
for more residents of mid-south with a
fleet of larger buses so two maybe three
maybe four
so i hope that if we're able to get in
some grant funding that we could
actually look very seriously at
expanding the scheme very much quicker
because
our original idea was to start off with
these two buses uh and then progress uh
but maybe we can go further sooner uh
and this is something certainly our side
of the house would support and i'm sure
your side of the house will support too
so i welcome the camaraderie if you like
that's broken out in the council chamber
today
i think it's absolutely wonderful that
you've actually accepted
one of our proposals
and i think perhaps the reasoning for
that was that we came up with one
proposal we didn't come up with a string
of proposals we came up with one
proposals actually making it very easy
for you
and making it very hard for you to
actually vote against it
thank you thank you councillor
councillor richardson
thank you chair i want to make a few
points in the budget but first i've got
a point of clarification for the chief
exec if i if i may it was just on the
question of the 5.1 million is it the
case that that's supposed to be spent
within the current financial year i just
wanted to clarify that point
happy to answer although i suspect
councillor whitehead can do as well um
no it's not so the original plan was
that that money would be spent over a
two-year period that two-year period
being the current financial year and the
forthcoming financial year so in effect
be spent by the march 2023.
thank you very much uh to the chief exec
for that answer and i'll and sheriff i
may have a few points on on the budget i
would like to make although i have to
say after cancer ebern's comments i'm
quite nervous about doing so i hope i
can't take anything too off-putting um i
think first just a general recognition
that everyone has touched on is our
relative financial position which is a
strong one it is a fortuitous one um and
i think that does give us that security
and i think it's worth reflecting on
just what an enviable position we are in
so i just by way of context i'm
currently on a
lga course at the minute where i'm
talking through with fellow um sort of
cabinet members from other local
authorities and they are aghast to the
kind of the flexibility we have and what
i do just want to reflect on is exactly
how um
important is that we do have both the
diverse income streams that we do enjoy
but also that very sort of cautious
control of what our spend is and that's
not just i don't think it's necessarily
i'm no finance expert but i don't think
that's necessarily just an underspend of
what we've allocated i think it's
actually a sustained effort to reduce
our overheads over the longer term so
this building being a perfect example of
that
um
especially and the reason i sort of
emphasized that point is exactly as
councillor whitehead said that level of
uncertainty and volatility given the
national picture and when i say national
picture i mean the national government
settlement um i think is really
important whether it's the new homes
bonus or the lack of certainty over the
business rates reform having that strong
financial position i think is is really
important
on the question of the council tax
freeze um i definitely support that
allowing in real terms um a cut for our
residents in terms of the amount of tax
they pay towards us um but also it
ensures as councillor passed more i
think as rotten mentioned as well a
freeze enables that degree of future
proofing for the council's finances over
the coming year when we know we're going
to face
inflationary pressures we know they're
going to be significant already but
after today's events they may well get
worse still
um in justin i think
finally if i can make one sort of last
point it's just about what this then
surplus enables us to do and so i really
welcome the comments that councillor
whitehead made both in setting out the
additional community spend that we can
make this year but also in accepting the
opposition's amendment and i do have to
say i think i agree with council scarf
that having a single sort of really
tangible detailed proposal made it far
easier for us to see how we can
accommodate that into
the broader corporate the six prior
corporate priorities we have as a
council um
what i think this fundamentally does is
surplus in this financial position
allows us to go beyond what we were what
is fundamentally the bare minimum in
terms of our statutory functions you
know we don't have to be an organization
that just
empties bins and maintains car parks we
can do so much more than that we should
be ambitious about what we want to
achieve in the future and i think that's
what this budget delivers um i certainly
is as unsurprisingly and i'm sure
councillor flatman would agree with me
if you want to spend more money on
communities and wellbeing i will never
say no um so i'm delighted to support
this um and and and thank of course
catherine in her last budget uh for her
contributions towards this and so many
budgets in the past uh so yes thanks to
all those involved and chair i will
sorry yes i'm wrapping up now i'll be in
voting in favor thank you cher
thank you councillor uh councillor
davies please
oops
this may not go down very well with the
technology i don't know um
i also welcome obviously the um
the freeze on
council tax
however i haven't had much time to look
at the documentation detail
so for our tenants
what do we do to help them in the time
of great financial squeeze
are we keeping the rents
um on zero increase for them
council whitehead
yeah um the the way the council finances
work is we have a general fund budget
which is basically everything except for
the housing revenue account which is
like a ring fence which is
the cost of keeping our council house
you know operating our council housing
so the next item on the agenda is the
housing revenue account so we'll come to
come to that in in a short while but um
the um
we do want to do all we can in terms of
um
helping our residents and
whether they're private renters owners
or council house tenants which is why we
you know we are freezing our council tax
thank you councillor uh councillor
wellam
thank you chair i just want to talk
about one thing um and that's about
buses
um
the uh the start of the work by the task
and finish group looking into rural
transport needs and provision has been
delayed but we will be starting that
work on the 14th of march
the head of passenger transport at the
county council will be assisting the
group
as a witness at that first meeting and
he has expressed his support for the
work
this group will be producing
recommendations and these may well guide
officers who will be investigating how
best to serve our residents with the
electric buses that have been proposed
in the opposition amendment which has
been adopted into the council's budget
by council of whitehead this is a real
opportunity for joint working of
officers members the county other
partners
we can and should get on with this work
we should get on with it now we need to
get the buses out there carrying
passengers as soon as possible thank you
thank you councillor councillor geek
thank you chair um
i was just wondering if the lack of
opposition support for budgets in the
past has been due to a lack of
administration support for opposition
budget amendments i'm glad to see that
the opposition the sorry i'm glad to see
that the administration is now beginning
to work with us
and i really hope that this will
continue
just a few details to share with you
about buses to show how much needed this
service is
in 2019 my village wool pit had seven or
eight buses a day in either direction
there are eight westwards and seven
eastwards in 2021 these were cut to five
and four per day now they're three and
two that's a catastrophic decline and it
means you simply can't rely on them in
particular the 8 a.m westward bus that
got people to school at thurston college
at bayton or work in berries and edmonds
that was the first one to be cut
and due to the decimation of the
services it's now practically impossible
to use the bus as a main form of
transport whether you're trying to get
to school or to college or to work or
even just to go shopping
and all this time we get more and more
housing built on the grounds that there
is a bus service in the village well
theoretically there is a bus service but
it's not one that's usable therefore
it's not one that's used therefore
there's no demand and this vicious
circle goes on please can we all work
together to break this vicious cycle i
thought i don't know how many of you use
buses in your in your daily lives but i
thought you might like some specific
detailed figures from one village
thank you councillor
are there any others who wish to speak
counselor hicks
thank you very much um just a couple of
things on the buses i think obviously we
need to be aware that suffolk as a
county we have applied for the bus back
beta scheme which will if we're
successful will allow us to obviously
run further buses around the county
that's sitting with the government at
the moment to make a decision and sadly
during covid we have seen i think it's a
67 percent decline today
in bus use compared to what it was
before covid because people are still
scared to get on buses and feel worried
about getting on the buses and of course
most of the bus routes aren't subsidised
they're private companies that are
running them and because users aren't
using them
they're stopping to run the buses which
is a great shame so i agree with cancer
geek to some degree is a vicious circle
of lack of use means that operators
don't want to run them etc um i i don't
want to upset cancer ebon at all
but i must say
as you would expect me to say and
obviously i welcome councillor
stringer's comment um that actually the
reason this is such a good
the reason you know we have we have a
very very strong track record on this
side of the chambers conservatives
conservatives are really well known for
running budgets that are well managed
organized and actually deliver for our
residents so i think it's absolutely
fantastic that councillor stringer
recognizes that it's the conservatives
that are delivering a strong budget and
i'm delighted you'll be voting with a
scouser stringer
[Applause]
point of clarification
sure i feel i feel much i feel knocked
out i feel not okay i'm terribly sorry
can ask for a point of clarification
please because i think there was some
confusion between what council
richardson mentioned on the 5 million
and what um councillor mansell said
because at last year's budget it was
that and i quote that the proposals the
budget proposals for 2122
so finishing this financial year would
include four million of spend to be
spent on um investment in local economy
housing wellbeing of residents blah blah
blah so it was that was the the the
fight the extra money as in between four
million and five point one might have
been over two years but the original
thing that we
agreed last year this time last year was
for the 4 million to be spent in this
financial year so i just want to make
sure it's in the minutes if you want to
look it up from last year's budget
meeting thank you chair
thanks thank you councillor eben um
um
arthur do you want to respond
yeah okay fine uh right uh counselor
melon
thank you chair um
yes i think uh thank you very much to my
colleagues um castlefield and councillor
ebern for their
uh proposal um on on the on the bus
thing uh i'm very glad to hear that
that's been
accepted
um but i'm also glad that we've been
reminded that we we did have a debate
last year
um
where uh four million was set aside
and that was to be spent
and now we're coming to the end of the
financial year and i did ask uh
councillor whitehead at the last meeting
how much of that money had been spent
and i think he said it was something
around about a quarter of a million
would have been spent by the end of the
financial year
um
we do i think welcome on this side the
the the naught percent rise in council
tax that is the key fact i think from
this budget um that our communities are
welcome and we welcome on this side and
of course i will remind you that that
was the proposal that we made last year
and of course uh i'm glad that you
eventually come around to our way of
thinking
um my concern
with the budget
uh um as of as i mentioned is this issue
of um actually delivering and spending
the money
so 4 million became 5.1 million and yet
we've spent only a tiny fraction of it
we have
500 000 set aside each year for the last
two years for climate spend we've only
spent 59 000 of it
and allocating the money is the easy bit
and it's something that you've managed
to do
delivery and spending the money seems to
be a much more difficult task
but i'm glad that you've taken on board
what i think was a fairly modest
proposal on this side of the house for
these buses
let's make it work let's get it going
i do have a couple of questions just in
clarification
uh and the first one of this um i wasn't
sure entirely what in what councillor
whitehead said whether um this would
then come back to cabin and be somehow
there'd be some sort of cabinet veto on
that so i'd really like some clarify
clarification
on that
and the second question is on the color
of the buses can we have one yellow and
one green thank you
thank you counselor melon for that
colorful end to your speech counselor
path more
well thank you chairman
really a point of information i suppose
i would just ask people to remember that
of course with the pandemic it has been
very difficult to get money spent we all
want value for money i'm not using that
entirely as an excuse but just to give
you some examples some of the grants
that um we award from the pcc's office
we've had to buy that over a period of
more than the original time so please
understand that the same has happened
with capital investment for building
program that's been delayed for all
sorts of reasons um a good challenge of
course but um please remember that and
on regard vacancies um in policing there
are about nine 10
staff vacancies i'm not talking about
officer numbers
sometimes we've had to fill those with
agency staff and that costs an absolute
damn fortune
and it's very difficult to get people to
apply and i know
this is being looked at about job
evaluation or whatever the system is so
please understand it's fine to say yeah
we need to look at the staff vacancies
and get them filled otherwise what's the
point of having them there but it is a
real real challenge and i suspect it's
the same in the county council health
service and everywhere else so it's a
big big issue for us all to tackle thank
you chairman
thank you councillor uh councillor
amoroson you have a question
thank you chair
uh a question for
um
uh chief exec or perhaps an officer um
is there any mechanism uh in
in law or in uh council regulations that
is um uh
is able to hold us as a council to
account for
uh
pledging for spending our pledges within
a certain
time period beyond
elections obviously is one it's one way
of doing it right but is there any other
is there any other mechanism for that
i'll try and answer the question i think
ultimately the answer to the question is
all of you um so through scrutiny
committees through audit committees
through challenging the administration
um and as you said through the
electorate
and at budget meetings in terms of the
debate that you've had here tonight so
um no ultimately you set a budget you
have to set a balanced budget that's the
that's the only legal requirement um but
you are then held to account by your
electorate in terms of the success of
delivering that budget
thank you arthur councillor molly
have no hesitation in seconding
this budget report
i want to start by paying tribute to
councillor whitehead's doggedness and
perseverance
in being able to make freezing council
tax a reality
i'm the first to admit i was not
convinced it was possible
normally we stand here and tell you that
we've managed to keep council tax to a
minimum
and that the mid-suffolk portion of
council tax is only going to go up by
the price of a cup of coffee per year
however last march we made the
considered decision that we would
attempt 0
this administration's careful management
of public money and the council's
finances
has put us in an almost unique position
compared to other councils
under councillor whitehead and katherine
steele's careful stewardship we have
become one of the most financially
strong and resilient councils in the
country
we can see just how unique and important
that is when we see other councils
having to make cuts to services and
staff numbers
my starting point is that it is
essential that we have sustainable
best-in-class council services that is a
given
i want to thank council catherine steele
and her team for all the hard work they
have put in
catherine has been an exemplar section
151 officer and public servant for
mid-suffolk and baber for many years
and as this will be catherine's final
mid-suffolk budget before she retires
i want to put on record my personal
thanks for her dedication and best
wishes for her retirement
we have built our financial strength
through a combination of additional
income and deficiencies
we have made the difficult and often
controversial decisions to invest in
things like cifco mid-suffolk growth and
gateway 14
and to share services with baber and
co-locate in endeavour house
all of these combined means that we can
invest for the long term and make the
biggest possible difference to our
residents lives
as rewarding as it might be having a
political disagreement in the chamber
can be
i know that all of us stand for election
because we want to make a difference
we want to make mid-suffolk an even
better place to grow up live work and
grow old
we want to make a difference to all our
residents lives and particularly to
those who are least able to help
themselves
so i'm most proud to second this budget
not because we're able to freeze council
tax this year not because we have more
income than our current service costs
because but because that means we can go
so much further to help people
we have massive aspirations to support
our residents in our business economy
we have already put in place over 5
million of additional initiatives to
help over the next two years and
although each of these initiatives are
time limited it is my hope that these
pilots will result in longer term
strategies that can be built into the
base budget
we also have other projects coming
forward that are being worked on
these haven't been finally costed yet
but will run into many millions
and as always we will look for external
funding sources to match fund our
investments
the chief exec often talks about trying
to get the council to a position where
we have more money than councillors know
what to do with councillor molly
but he always then caveats that with the
fact that we will never succeed because
we councillors will always find ways to
spend that money he's right
i want to end fuel
energy digi digital and food poverty in
mid-suffolk i want to end homelessness
in mid-suffolk i want us to end carbon
emissions in mid-suffolk and i want to
provide more genuinely affordable homes
for our residents greater employment
opportunities and increased biodiversity
and i don't want us to stop there
i want us to do these things not for
myself not just because they are the
right thing to do because they are
things that ultimately make an actual
difference to the quality of people's
lives
i commend this budget to the chamber and
i hope you will vote to support it
[Applause]
thank you councillor morley
before i call on councillor whitehead to
if he wishes to add anything further
well i'm pretty sure he does
um
i'd like i'd like to say a few words um
first of all um can i say that it's been
a youthful and worthwhile debate
and
i think that there's no doubt that
across this chamber
um we all want to achieve more for our
residents i have no doubt about that
and we might disagree about some of the
approaches that we might take to that
but i can
i can definitely look at my residence in
the face and assure them that this
council and its officers are working
very hard to try and deliver the best
that they possibly can for their
well-being
and and the economic outlook that they
can face going forward
so
i'd like to point out that in any
organization of which and this is one
ideas don't come from one particular
group we look for ideas from all sources
so let's not get too bogged down about
where the ideas come from let's really
worry about whether they're truly good
ideas that we can set out good plans to
implement that will benefit our
residents
and as we know
we have some very core principles within
our councils and we're all working very
hard to to try and deliver on those uh
particular principles and i mean i take
the point that uh councillor matheson
made but we know we have a biodiversity
policy we have committed funds to it we
are absolutely keen to achieve the best
sustainable outcomes in our district so
i have no doubt that we're traveling
along the right kind of path so i would
encourage everybody to participate in
this work because it's vital that we are
all doing that and that our residents
see that we're all doing that
and with that i'd like to pass the floor
to a couple of white head to round up
thank you chairman um it's been a very
good debate and maybe it's just that you
remember the
bruises more than the the other times
when it's come to these boats but i
shall certainly at some stage soon want
to look back and just sort of see where
the voting was because sort of my
recollection was perhaps perhaps it's
wrong
um but um they
one problem we do seem to have when it
comes to
like spending this is five million
pounds um it's basically the capacity of
the organization i know we can go
outside and find things elsewhere but
i read more and more about the um the
fact that there's
like one and a quarter million vacancies
in the country and everybody every
company private sector public sector
just does seem to struggle to recruit
uh so that that is a concern because the
uh i think there's five million pound of
projects has to be like 14 fixed term
contract people that need these need to
be recruited now in the process of being
recruited to deliver them so they there
definitely are challenges with spending
money there's no doubt about it
but um i uh i look forward to this
ongoing uh
agreement across the council chamber i'm
not quite sure if it's supposed to be a
swords length apart or not but anyway i
tend to keep my weapons at home the uh
the only thing i'd just like to say and
i just it was really just um to
councillor mellon's um suggestion that
these buses are going to be running
around with suffolk so i'd be happy to
ask ipswich town supporters throughout
mid-suffolk whether they like the idea
of the yellow and green buses
i must i must say that whether it's
supporting the football
election time or even now when i wait
for one of these new buses to come i'll
be saying come on you blues
thank you
[Applause]
thank you councillor whitehead
right
in accordance with council procedure
rule 19.3
immediately after any vote is taken at a
budget decision meeting of the council
of which this is one the names of
councillors who cast a vote for the
decision or against the decision or who
abstain from voting shall be recorded in
the minutes of that meeting
the recorded vote will also be published
on the council's website
the vote is going to be taken
electronically through modern.gov
i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the recorded vote
on the motion
thank you chair that vote is now showing
in blue with the amendment showing as
well if you can cost your vote please
thank you
okay i can take yep four thank you
and councillor pat i believe okay thank
you
uh
okay
that is a unanimous vote for
[Applause]
well thank you all for that um it's now
approximately uh seven o'clock and i
think actually would be a good point of
which if we could take a five minute
break
thank you
right uh councillors
we're going to move now to item 9b on
the agenda
this is paper mc oblique 2-1 oblique 2-7
housing revenue account
2022-23 budget
i would like to invite councillor
whitehead to introduce the paper and to
move the recommendations in the report
councillor whitehead
thank you thank you chair now yeah i
needed that family vote to get over that
i'm sorry that five minute break over
that unanimous vote
[Laughter]
the housing revenue account um i'd like
to introduce the this
budget report
now the headlines in this housing
revenue budget and the main proposal
being voted on it's undoubtedly the 4.1
increase in our housing rent
we're sure all of us must have real
concerns regarding such an uplift given
the other given the other cost of living
pressures that we know are in the
pipeline for our residents
government has to quite a few years now
set out guidance and limits for the
year-on-year changes to our council
house rent levels we had five years up
to march 20 and we were obliged to
reduce rents in each of those years by
one percent so reduction marginally over
five percent in that period
which has been truly challenging for our
housing revenue account
since 2020 we've been allowed to
increase by cpi plus one percent which
led to modest increases
but this year though inflation has moved
far over the government's own target
leading to just proposed 4.1 rent
increase
we expect to start the year 2223 with
hra reserves just under 3 million
and 3 million just sound like a decent
sized number but with over 3 000 houses
it equates less than a thousand pound
per house
in addition even with this four pokemon
rent increase we're only anticipating a
marginally above break-even position for
the budget
so in this new year we'll be adding very
little to reserves
it i believe all of us on both sides of
this chamber have great ambitions to
improve our castle house stock
historically we spent money on
replacements to kitchens bathrooms doors
and windows when they were needed but
going forward that's no longer enough we
must look beyond that
better installation improved heating
systems
and other measures to bring all our
housing stock in due course up to epc
level of c
we make that investment and our housing
residents gain the benefits in terms of
living in higher quality housing
we simply can't achieve that we've
reserved just a thousand pound per
dwelling
so this 4.1 rent increase which is 3
pound 42 for social rents or 4.99 an
average for affordable rents
that will generate extra hr our hra
income of nearly 3 6 million pounds over
10 years now that is vital extra funding
you know our ambitions haven't been
helped by the covered pandemic which has
negatively impacted our housing revenue
account
our new build program has been seriously
delayed due to lockdown measures and
social distancing
and our maintenance and repair program
has likewise been affected
the learning experience from this
current year has been built into the
budget expenditure next year 22-23
that includes a 14 uplift on building
services
from this current year's budget to next
year's budget
now that on the face might seem
excessive or over-proven but the rather
depressing reality
is that this merely
compares
the new budget on a realistic basis
there are still backlogs to be caught up
and there is without doubt a greatly of
inflationary pressure on building
materials and supplies
we are proposing to keep garage rents
and sheltered housing services charges
frozen at the current levels
and making modest increases to sheltered
housing utilities but they will still
include an element of cross subsidy
as well as our clear determination to
improve our current housing stock we
also have an ambitious new build program
our cove has delayed that so we have
total of 21.5 million capital carry
forward
along with 17.6 million of new capital
funding
over the next four years we have
identified development sites to deliver
341 homes
a welcome increase in our housing stock
for those residents most in need of a
new house to call home
i'd like to move the recommendations
itemized in paragraphs 3.1 3.7 of the
report
and repeat a sincere hope that this
housing revenue account also will have
cross-party consensus
i'll ask the cabinet member for fine for
housing if she will kindly second those
recommendations thank you chair
thank you chair i'm happy to second that
and observe my right to speak thank you
thank you councillor
we will now move to questions
and can we make sure questions are
questions succinct and to the point and
about facts
you will have time in the debate to make
other points
councillor mathson
thank you chair yeah um
looking at recommendation
3.6 where where the um the the pos you
know if there's a budgeted surplus
um it's going to be transferred to
strategic priorities reserve
um
can we i just wonder whether if over in
previous years we've transferred quite a
lot of money there um could we not
transfer the odd million or two from
strategic priorities back into the hra
councillor whitehead
but my understanding but i'll certainly
ask um catherine to just clarify as well
is that that strategic priorities
reserve is within the housing revenue
account that is the principal and the
largest reserve
and that is there for
improvements et cetera
you have one more question councillor
yeah so i'll let everyone else go
afterwards um yes
just to clarify that i was asking
that that's the strategic priorities we
serve within the hra is it i see what i
was asking about was whether we can pop
the odd million or two across from the
from the general fund into hra
i wonder if
catherine still would just clarify that
for the councillor please
yes thank you chair no unfortunately we
can't because the hra is ring fence so
the general fund and money that we
raised through council cancelled
taxpayers can't be used to subsidise the
housing revenue account and vice versa
so unfortunately no that can't happen
thank you just to continue the theme a
little
is it also illegal to say reduce the
chart cost charge from from the
main budget main revenue account to the
housing revenue account for one year to
allow us to waive the
increase for just one period time period
catherine still please
thank you chair um we have to make
allowance within the
housing revenue account for overheads
you know it has to pay for its
proportion and that is something that we
have to
talk to the orders about when they look
at the accounts so i know the auditors
would look um ask lots of questions if
we didn't actually charge those
overheads and it is something that is
rightly borne by the housing revenue
account because
myself as an officer i work equally
across the general fund and the hra so
part of my time along with a lot of
other things need to be a portion
between the two
so again i don't think that's an option
in terms of not doing that over overhead
recharge to to the hra
thank you uh councilmember
thank you on a similar theme
are we allowed to loan money from our
general fund to the uh housing revenue
account at a low rate of interest
section five one five one officer
i'm not sure that there is actually any
benefit because we can get cheap money
from the market so i don't think there
is any benefit um if if there was a such
a transfer between the general fund and
the hra it would need to be done that
sort of market rate so i don't think
there is any any benefit and it's a loan
so it's it's got to be repaid so if we
were looking at loans for the hra then
we would use the market rather than sort
of internally
councilor willem
chair thank you i'm going to continue on
the same theme
there are biodiversity improvements i
believe planned for hra land
do they have to be funded from the hra
account or can they be funded from the
general fund we've got a million pounds
to spend why don't we spend some of that
on hra land instead of having to come
out the hra budget
whose best place
catherine if we could call on you again
please
now thank you chef just conferring with
my colleague and that that may be an
area we could actually explore because
some of our
some of our estates are a mixture of
council tenants and uh private tenants
as well so yeah that could be an area
that we could look to to use general
fund monies
thank you very much
uh right if there are no fur
council stream
okay so we're going to move to debate
then um so the usual rules apply three
minutes
and you will be timed uh who would like
to kick off the debate
councillor matheson i i will then right
i'd like to just uh thank colleagues for
their um sterling efforts in creative
accounting there
which was eventually successful we hope
is that it
right just want to say about the hra it
is
galling the way hras are are constructed
but of course they've been constructed
by something called a government
which means they're actually not quite
fit for purpose when we are hitting
huge financial pressures
inflation
we are being asked to now
raise costs
for some of those that can least afford
it
which is against every fiber of my being
and against most of your
political philosophies allegedly so
surely
given the amount of
lobbying
that
the administration is able to do a
central government we should be able to
construct a way
that this bizarre situation shouldn't
occur we've got a number of crises
at our door the debt cap has been
lifted now thank goodness
but surely we should be
harnessing the value the equity that we
have in this housing stock
to address
part of the
fuel crisis
by having a huge program of insulating
our homes and bringing them up to
standard we have so much headroom in the
value of this
we should already be doing it so i i
won't be supporting the hra sorry to
break the loving
because it is going to
disproportionately affect those that at
least can can afford but why have we not
got a position where we have gotten a
government that recognizes the crisis
allows that mechanism to happen within
an hra to use that headroom to deliver
two prices for the price of one thank
you chad
thank you chair i was just gonna keep it
very brief um
we understand the the the pressures
within in the housing revenue account
and the
the desperate need to improve things
like fuel efficiency and insulation and
and all the costs that go with that
process
i think as uh councillor stringers just
said that we are also very concerned as
i think council whitehead was himself
at increasing the rent on on a segment
of the population that can he'll afford
that
i'm also always concerned that
we we keep harking back to the period
when the government insisted that we
reduced
council rents by one percent per annum
and as i recall that that came after
well for this council after a debate
where we put the council rents up
and we were told
don't worry about it guys
nearly half of our residents have their
rents paid for by the government through
housing benefit
and the government is not quite as daft
as we think it is it responded it forced
us to back off to reverse our decision
a decision that was obviously not just
this councils it belonged to a whole
variety of councils across the country
so
my concern is if you like twofold we're
building ourselves another problem with
the government
and we're also hurting a particularly
disadvantaged portion of the population
so
i won't be voting for this uh somewhat
regrettably there's a lot in there that
is it that is good and a lot of
ambitions that we we need to follow
through
thank you
thank you chair i i agree with both my
fellow
councils on this side of the uh on on
this side of the room uh and i i just
wanted to re-quote something that
councillor whitehead said when he was
talking about the general fund
and i have actually written down some
notes which i i probably can't even read
properly but i believe he said that he
really wants to help those residents who
are struggling the most
i think that was that were his very
words um
and really um
i don't think increasing um the council
house rents is
um helping those residents who are
struggling the most
and we've just had um
some examples of perhaps a little bit of
creative thinking um in our questions um
so maybe there is another answer i
realize that there are a lot of
pressures and we do want to improve our
housing stock we do want to improve
insulation we want to improve energy
efficiency to make it much easier for
those those people in the most um who
are struggling the most to pay their
bills
but um maybe
we should be a little bit more creative
and and do do it a different way so i'm
afraid i can't be supporting uh this
motion thank you
thank you councillor um
councillor morley
i wasn't actually planning on saying
anything to this newspaper but
given the comments that have just been
made i feel i do need to correct some
misunderstanding
we already apply a 95
reduction
to our council
our
social housing residents who are most in
need
so
stating that you can't support it
because we're not giving help
is just quite frankly not true
it is means tested and those who are in
need get a 95 percent reduction
in this rent
thank you councillor
councillor willem
thank you jeff um i don't think i dozed
off but could i just be reminded by
councillor whitehead of the information
that was requested by overview and
scrutiny committee if he has it to hand
now we're asked to agree a zero increase
in garage rents
we've supported a zero increase in
council tax
um
now both of those
will benefit to a greater extent those
who live in large houses and drive cars
so we're not benefiting to the same
degree
the people who
really need it the most those who are
living in the smaller houses those who
are living in council houses and i think
we should be we should be
favoring them not favoring the others
thank you
thank you councillor
councillor more
just a very quick point chairman if i
may
yes we've heard that a lot of people do
get substantial help with their rent i'm
sure
we're all concerned about those who are
in difficulty um that's very very
important but don't also forget that the
government has provided that 150 pound
rebate for council tax overall as well
for those i think was it a bad deal
below property so there is help there
the freezing accounts tax i do
understand what you're all saying but i
think in this particular instance there
is enough mitigation and i shall
certainly be supporting the proposal and
i do absolutely agree if we could have
more freedom and autonomy on the hra i
think those of us who've been here since
the year dot have always said that and
um i just think it's regrettable that
government doesn't give you more
autonomy for this and there's plenty of
other things as well so um that's my
view thank you
thank you
um
we do need to be mindful that yes
people who have been currently mean
tested
are getting that
rebate
but
you'd be after mindful that there are
people in all of our wards but certainly
are mine people who
are struggling with two jobs
barely keeping on the breadline
who are
on
doing everything can because they are do
not wish to ask for benefits they do not
wish to be in a position where they have
to live on handouts
and some of them are going where they
are going without food to feed their
children
and this is the case that is currently
in the condition it's going to get worse
this is about information that we've
been given from the see instead of ice
we are being keeping this by their
situation is going downhill
and these are people who i would
everyone would say these are people in
most dire need
and to be
considering there's been these
properties which are
if they are in ignition bandy where they
need to be
better insulated where people are
struggling to pay for either choosing to
put food in a table or pay the heating
bill which we are in that situation at a
moment now
where we have
uh
all this addition we have the people who
well if we are indulged in but we're
going to be asked now
we can improve your home for you
we can put you in a better position
where you're not gonna have to worry
about heating so much
we're not gonna do it
uh we know that you currently don't have
the money
you
already there uh but to get there you're
gonna have to pay for it
we're not gonna say where this money is
gonna come from we're
working magic maybe
climb up the magic money tree it's not
there
so these people are proud who have put
themselves
their own health at risk by putting
themselves
not to go on these handouts
we're going to give them no other choice
but to go on these government handouts
so either we're going to put more of the
government at a greater risk where it's
going to go back on those we can turn
around and say you've done this what
you're thinking about doing
if you can begin to wrap up counsellor
well
we know the situation
it's got worse it's getting worse
and it's saying you can get out of it we
can improve it we're going to make it
greener but it's going to cost you
that's not helping anyone
thank you
thank you councillor carter councillor
scarf
did you wish to speak
uh thank you chair um well it's a very
small part of the overall housing
revenue account but i wanted to focus on
the right to buy sales and i accept
that in the paragraph 4.25 we actually
sold less than we expected to sell but
it's still
houses that we lose and for every house
that we lose
we don't get to keep all of the money
and i think that is an absolute travesty
if
the right to buy scheme worked well
it would enable our tenants to receive a
discount and buy a house at a discount
and allow us to use the full receipt
from that sale to build a new one and
that surely has to be the way forward
and i think
everything we can do to put pressure on
the government to change that would be
welcome
paragraph
uh
4.27 says the council can enter into
agreements with the secretary of state
to retain the full right to buy receipt
from the sale of nominated homes newly
built or acquired since july 2008.
officers will investigate opportunities
to enter into agreements that any
capital receipts received in future from
the sale of those nominated homes could
be retained in full and used as part of
the 60 match funding required because we
only get to keep 40 of the original sale
so i would urge that the officers do do
that at the earliest opportunity so that
that small amount extra
can add into the housing revenue account
and can enable us to do things like
retrofitting and more of the repairs and
more of those kinds of issues because i
think although it's quite a small amount
it is still it is still significant
if we don't spend the money within the
five-year period we have to return it to
government with a four percent above
base rate uh payment on top uh i've
sought assurance in the past that we we
do actually manage to spend that and i
hope that we continue to do that because
the thought of paying the government
back with four percent above the base
rate on top
is to me horrific so i think if we can
focus on that and get those
opportunities to enter into agreements
with central government
to enable us to do more with the housing
revenue account i think that would be a
good step forward so thank you
thank you councillor scarf councillor
amarosa
thank you chair um
uh so admittedly i'm a great head for
this kind of uh nuanced uh
mathematics however i'm wondering if
there is a
potential paradox here whereby
within with raising inflation rates it's
going to bring so many more residents of
council hazing stock
into
qualifying for
help with with rent
and also
this additional uh
rent increase will
uh worsen their their circumstances and
so how many more residents are going to
be are we going to be helping with their
rent to to pay this extra rent so is
there a kind of
uh where does the equation balance there
you know
um
and has that been has that been
considered i guess
thanks
thank you councillor uh council of war
boys
thank you chip
uh
well in
the spirit of this evening's debates i
think and the the humor
i i can't sympathize
so we could hear you better i'm sorry
that's it thank you sorry i'm
speaking to myself
um
and spirit of this evening's um debate i
i just want to ask a question sort of a
little bit of joined up thinking perhaps
i
i appreciate council whitehead's
concerns about
there's simply not enough income
to meet the needs
of our housing stock
to get our housing stock up
to the standards that are
our um residents
deserve
i i don't think anyone's going to argue
the fact that our
council housing supplies a very very
real need and we want to do the best
possible
for our residents
elsewhere
the council has borrowed 100 million
pounds
to invest in council offices
to provide income to the council
um
i'm not sure what the state of this
income is at the moment whether it's
being paid or it's accruing
um
what council whitehead's problem and the
problem in the
hra count is a lack of
revenue
rather than
increasing forcing an increase of rents
on our existing residents
kind of suggests we actually borrow
money from the public's work board
invest in
new council houses
which are energy efficient
and
use that as a way of increasing the
revenue in the hra account
thank you
thank you councillor
uh
right
sorry councillor geek
thank you chair um given everything that
the uh
councillors opposite have said it seems
remarkable to me that anyone is liable
to pay this 4.1 rise it's so thoroughly
mitigated i can't i can almost not
imagine the kind of circumstances you'd
be in to pay this rise but um
as uh councillor amoroson suggests it's
also possible on on analogy with the
laffer curve
on tax cuts which i'm sure we're all
familiar with keeping the rents down
might not lead to a much lower income
and
i think to be able to
assess that we need to um to hear the
details from councillor whitehead on how
many tenants qualify for the rent rebate
which uh
unless i've had a micro sleep i wasn't
aware that um that we'd heard so far so
i'll await that with interest thank you
thank you councillor um
i'm afraid councillor amoroson you've
already had your
sorry it's not a
question
well i'm sure that councillor whitehall
whitehead will respond to you in when he
gets up to speak
thank you i was just wondering if um if
councillor whitehead wants to speak
first
um but if everyone else has spoken then
i'm happy to speak um anyway um i'd like
to say i'm very sorry that the loving is
finished and um and it seems that we're
not getting the support from the other
side of the the
chamber tonight
um but but anyway we are where we are
and and as you've heard earlier the hra
is ring fenced
and um
much as i'd like to transfer heaps of
cash over from the general fund that is
not available and um and our ambitions
for energy efficient new bills that we
can be proud of and to bring our council
stock up to an epc um
level epc c level and above um
unfortunately um it is why we have come
you know with this rent increase and the
rest of the hra um
proposes before you and so i'm
terribly sorry that you know you're not
gonna support this but anyway i hope you
can change your mind and um and really
think about why we're actually doing
this and i do want to assure keith that
we're going to do all we can to spend um
the right to buy receipts that we can
possibly do thank you very much
thank you
him uh councillor whitehead
thank you um
i think everything i've heard i
very much sympathize with i think um
might ultimately come down to the
difference between
when you're in administration you have
the responsibilities to
to to make difficult decisions and in
opposition you do have the luxury of
voting against and
maybe
rolls reverse would be we
would be doing the same but um my
understanding is this this four point
one percent it's
i can't say that every council is doing
it but i believe all the ones in in
suffolk where whatever color their
administration are are putting this for
one percent through i'm pretty sure that
and everything that votes for it does it
does it with a heavy heart
but the
and in terms of the question of how many
people are on benefits and get their
housing support i think i've heard
figures from 45 percent to 60 percent so
i'm not
completely sure where it is but some
somewhere around a half perhaps
slight less than a half or up to 60
percent
you know either have
um
full benefits paid or
or close to that
um
the lowest social rent we've got in uh
mid-suffolk is after this increase is 50
pound 96 a week or 221 pound a month
and the highest social rent 119 pound
and four pence which is 556 pounds a
month which i mean even the highest one
there is
my understanding is that's significant
less than a private renter would pay for
even a probably a modest one-bedroom or
two-bedroom flat in in mid-south and if
they're looking for a semi-detached
house
to rent in the private sector they're
probably paying
i don't know 700 to 1000 pounds so it's
you know i think
a lot of people look on those rents and
the reason there is a long housing list
is it's um
you know it's
it is subsidized housing uh it's it's
housing well below market rent
so um they uh and we did say i said in
my speech we 341 new homes were
proposing to
deliver over the next four years that's
on a housing soccer watch 3200 so that's
a decent number more it'll take up to
three and a half thousand
by
2026.
um
so
um i say with a heavy heart i shall vote
for this increase and um because
it is needed we have to do it it's
responsibility that i'm not prepared to
shirk thank you
thank you councillor whitehead
uh council in accordance with council
procedure rule
19.3 immediately after any vote is taken
at a budget decision meeting of the
council the names of councillors who
cast a vote for the decision or against
the decision
or who abstain from voting shall be
recorded in the minutes of that meeting
the recorded vote will also be published
on the council's website
i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the recorded vote
thank you chair that vote is now showing
in blue if councillors could cast their
vote thank you
thank you
oh it's just come through thank you
sorry about that
chair the votes are 16 4 and 16 against
so can i ask you are you exercising your
casting vote
i will be so doing
okay can i take your vote please that
will be full
okay so that is carried then
thank you
right
mc oblique 2-1 oblique 2-8
joint capital investment and treasury
management strategies for
2022-23
i would like to invite councillor miller
to introduce paper mc oblique21 oblique
to eight and to move the recommendations
in the report counselor
thank you chair i am pleased to
introduce this report which we discussed
at our meeting on the 24th of january
under the sipher treasury management
code of practice and the prudential code
both published in 2021 and the
department for levelling up and housing
and communities investment guidance
published in 2018 we are required to
determine separate capital investment
and tm strategy statements and
prudential indicators annually before
the start of each financial year
there have been no significant changes
in format this year and it has been
updated to reflect the latest capital
expenditure investment and borrowing and
the latest treasury management
investment and borrowing positions of
the council the strategies and
indicators to be approved are in the
appendices to the report and i will now
give an overview of each of these
appendix a the capital strategy this
summarizes the capital expenditure and
financing requirements of the full
capital programme for both general fund
and hra the details of which are in the
budget report
this sets out capital expenditure and
capital investment decisions and the
associated risks and rewards along with
how risk is managed for future financial
sustainability
it includes prudential indicators which
demonstrate that the investment plans
the councils are affordable prudent and
sustainable and decisions are made
according to good practice
it shows that capital expenditure
planned for 2223
including carry forward is 68.2 million
of which 52.6 million will be funded by
borrowing
you limits and boundaries for borrowing
are set as part of the credential
indicators
the strategy shows that projected
borrowing will not exceed these limits
appendix b is the investment strategy
this details those expenditure items in
the capital program that specifically
relate to assets bought and or owned by
the councils purely or partially to
generate a return
this includes schemes which have the
purpose of regeneration or development
of the local area
as well as generating a return
in the context of this strategy
investments means those non-treasury
management activities
the dluhc investment guidance defines
these as two types of investments
first service provision where the
councils lend to our lend to or buy
shares in organizations that provide a
service such as gateway 14 for the
purpose of regeneration and economic
development
secondly for investments for yield where
the primary purpose is to generate a
return such as the council owned
companies cifco
this strategy explains how each
investment contributes to the council's
priorities and security liquidity and
risk
it shows the projected total investment
of the council in cifco the growth
companies in gateway 14 and planned
expenditure on the council's property
held at least in part for investment
purposes
appendix c is the treasury management
strategy 2223
which sets out the council's borrowing
requirement and borrowing and treasury
management investment strategies this
also includes the list of approved
investment counterparties and limits
there have been no significant change
since to limits since last year
appendix d is the treasury management
indicators which we use to measure and
manage the council's exposure to
treasury management risks appendix e
economic update and interest rate
forecast the ongoing impact on the uk
from covid19 together with higher
inflation the likelihood of higher
interest rates and the country's trade
position post-brexit will be major
influences on the council's treasury
management strategy for 2223
at the time of writing this report the
authority's treasury management advisor
arlene close was forecasting that the
bank of england bank rate will rise to
0.5 percent in the first quarter of 2022
and remain at this level until at least
the final quarter of 2024
arlene close has since revised this
forecast and now expects the bank rate
to rise to 1 by the middle of 2022
appendix f current investment and debt
portfolio shows the position at the 30th
november 2021. the borrowing for
mid-suffolk is
132.9 million of which 105.4 million is
long-term at fixed rates and 27.5
million short term
on the investment side mid-suffolk has
19.75 million invested this includes
ccla ubs schroders invest tech and
funding circle we have continued the
policy withdrawing funds from funding
circle as loans drop out and we have not
invested any new money
appendix g the treasury management
policy statement underpins the strategy
and sets up the council's regard to the
monitoring of risk and performance and
the primary objectives remain security
of capital then liquidity followed by
return
appendix h the minimum revenue provision
statement which shows the basis on how
we put aside the resources to repay
debts in later years finally appendix i
shows the institutions meeting high
credit ratings criteria and appendix j
is a glossary of terms
now i'd like to propose the
recommendations are set out in three one
two three seven of the report
subject to tables one two seven and
chart one in appendix a and table two in
appendix c being updated following the
earlier amendment to the general fund
budget and would ask for a second thank
you jeff
thank you councillor muller could i have
a second to please uh counselor casten
thank you very much mr chairman happy to
second that and would like to reserve my
right to speak
thank you council casten
uh we're going to move two questions
councillor matheson
thank you chair yeah the the um
i i was looking to see
the extent to which our capital
programme
had been delayed
uh by covid as it accepted it inevitably
will have been but the the table one
appendix a that's on page 103
um it doesn't actually show
what the
the budget was for 20 to 21 or of indeed
for 21 22 the current year that we've
got a forecast out turn
um i can't compare either of those two
years with the budget that was
originally
intended officers can help me with that
what is your question yeah the question
is can i see the the budget
to compare with those first two columns
of that
table table one page 103.
thank you
counselor muller
okay so matheson for your question could
i ask
catherine please to answer that question
thank you
thank you chair um
the purpose of this report isn't
actually to give the performance against
the budget
um this is a different type of report
and the performance against the budget
is included in the quarterly reports to
cabinet because that covers both the
general fund position and our capital
position so if a councillor wanted to
see more information in terms of our
performance against the capital budget
as say we have issued quarter two
already which was in december for
cabinet and quarter three will be coming
to cabinet very shortly uh in march so
next month
thank you uh councillor ebern
thank you very much chair um thank you
councillor miller for your report
in appendix c
under environment social and governance
issues
under
paragraph 5.18
it
says about how we will be just
monitoring
aspects of environment social and
governance
and the cabinet will be looking at those
could you
tell me how does that sit with the fact
that in the paragraphs beforehand it
says about we've declared a climate
emergency and the fact that when um your
committee um
made a recommendation to cabinet cabinet
then rejected that recommendation so i'm
unclear as to how that rejection of that
recommendation sits with um that
paragraph 5.18 if you could clarify that
for me i'd be much appreciated thank you
chancellor muller uh thank you counselor
eberton for your question yes um you're
right the cabinet did initially reject
that but we have to consider all the
aspects not just the you know the social
social economic etc perhaps catherine
still might be able to add any further
to that thank you catherine thank you
thank you
so chair i might wish to invite perhaps
the the finance cabinet member to make
some comment because there was much
debate at the cabinet meeting in regards
to what was put forward to to uh cabinet
from the joint audit and standards so
you may wish to wish to comment further
on that
thank you uh councillor whitehead do you
wish
sorry
i've been
stroking this microsoft service up and
down
i'm just quite happy now but um
i uh
could you just tell me what appendix was
adding please because i'm just
appendix c page 135 pages
from the committee
well my understanding i'm
struggling to
have been quite a long day actually but
i think
i think we were sort of taking a wider
or more
holistic approach to the whole
the whole thing rather than say having a
narrow focus on
the climate change situation to look at
the whole environmental social and
government's governance side of it but i
think i might uh
might better
respond perhaps outside of the meeting
because i i'm
i'm not totally clear myself to be
honest
counselor eben
sorry chair but if it might help if i
clarify because the the statement on
5.18 says that cabinet agreed to monitor
but i don't understand i i just well i
do understand but i just need would like
you to give me some clarification how
that works when we've got a committee
called joint audit and standards that
makes recommendations whatever they're
on you know and so therefore how is that
surely that monitoring is part of what
the audience stands committee does
that's what i'm not clear on thank you
chair
council whitehead
right i think it
it's almost coming down to some of the
earlier things we've talked about in
terms of the constitution where where
things sort of fall between audit
between overview and scrutiny and
cabinet etc um
all i know from reading this and
thinking back to the discussions we had
back in january that we wanted to
monitor
uh
treasury management
through over the whole spectrum of
environmental social governance and it
is a very big spectrum there's so many
aspects of it
and certainly there's a cabinet that was
um our determination
um
but i'm i'm struggling really to sort of
answer beyond that to be honest at the
moment
i'm compelled to uh
to raise the alarm
actually
i was part of that auditing standards
committee
where
there was a lively debate
around this issue
there was disagreement
and after some discussion
there was near if not absolute
unanimous decision that um
that we should
divest from fossil fuels
i want to read out from a from a think
tank uh
who do very rigorous uh studies on
on councillor can you move to your
question i've got a
brilliant question
um
so they say they say
adoption of renewables
is growing exponentially
worldwide
and disruption is now inevitable by 2030
they will offer the cheapest electricity
option for most regions coal gas and
nuclear power
assets will become stranded
during the 2020s
and no new investment in these
technologies is rational from this point
forward
so
i just i need to know
why as a council and i feel like
irresponsible
being part of a council that is
why are we
going forward with this
uh not just from an ethical
sustainability point of view but from a
purely economic point of view councillor
please sit down thank you very much
why
so
at pain of repeating myself if you're
going to stand up to ask a question i
expect you to answer to ask a question i
did and i don't want
war and peace beforehand
okay
you have plenty of time to have your war
on peace when we have debate
and i don't feel that i need i should
have to tell you to desist
more
okay i just thought this was debate
no we were on questions i do beg your
pardon okay can i have my question
answered
indeed we will attempt to answer your
question but if the if the relevant
cabinet member is not able to answer it
straight away then they will have to
answer it outside of this meeting
councillor whitehead
thank you um
councilman has just got me the uh
the uh
the sort of minutes if you like of the
um
cabinet meeting where
it was resolved that
cabinet would monitor treasury
management in relation to all three
aspects of esg reporting as it developed
the reason for that was to ensure the
wider issues around environmental
social and governance are considered in
relation to treasury management
investments and not just the
environmental issues raised by joint
audit and standards committee but i
think thinking about now the capital
just felt that it's very very large and
important
field a whole field of environmental
social and governance and it was felt
that the um
the joint audit and standards really had
just focused very much on
one or two strands of just the
environmental side so sorry
i can't i can't
i've just brought up the economic
argument does anyone else have any
questions
all right no one else wants to i
i'd like to to help councillor whitehead
um
in answering councillor amaroson's
question
and indeed um uh council rebels question
really um he he said and i i have some
transcript of the relevant part of that
uh cabinet meeting uh he he he based his
belief that the um
the
fossil fuel investments would go up
and not down
on gut instinct and that's a quote
i could just respond and say that with
brent oil now 104 dollars a barrel i was
my good instinct was pretty right
because i think at the time of the
meeting in january it was somewhere
around seventy dollars a barrel so
it's actually gone up fifty percent in
two months
very good point
does anyone else counselor amarosa
you have three minutes
so
yeah we're talk we're not looking at the
spikes and troughs of the day-to-day
[Music]
trading
fluctuations we're looking at the
investment trends for the next
10 years
or so
[Music]
and by all accounts
the
the trend for adoption of
renewables in terms of investment is
exponential and the decline of
investment in terms of
traditional coal nuclear etc
is is going to be exponentially the
other way
so
so
this is this is what i'm trying to get
across to you let's not get distracted
by
by short-term fluctuations when we know
the uh the longer-term trends or we're
relatively certain
thank you
uh
council humphreys
mr chairman thank you i'll get your
point um i'm not a financial expert and
i don't do the markets very often but i
do know like like council white had said
it's not just peaks and troughs always
been continually growing of course one
day we'll stop using it it's fine what
about when we get nuclear fusion should
we not go down the nuclear route
no i'm not asking who's throwing it out
there
it's not irrelevant it's as irrelevant
as your points the point is the point is
that they've decided in the direction
they're going and whether you think it's
right or wrong doesn't really matter
it's just subjective it's your
perception and my perception isn't the
same as yours
that's all i'd like to say
thank you councillor casten
um
these investments that we're talking
about um i don't believe we're talking
about the schroeder investment fund i
don't believe there's
um an amount in nuclear
or coal fired power stations it's a
fossil fuel
issue that we had there's a proportion
of that fund in fossil fuels but um
i think um
the answer to your question why
has cabinet not accepted
this um coming out of audit is because
um
cabinet has considered it and not
accepted it just like
because scrutiny
wants to force taxi drivers to buy
electric cars
it doesn't mean that it doesn't mean
that the cabinet has to adopt it
what
um
so what i'd like to say is um
thank you very much councillor muller
for all the work you do on this um audit
and standards committee he works
extremely hard as do all the councillors
on that committee we have
big
pieces of work put in front of us and
every single one of those person people
go through it diligently and with a huge
amount of care and it takes a lot of
time and
i'd also like to um thank the producers
of this report because it does arrive in
a very good and
and well
written competent way
that um that helps that a lot so um yeah
i'd like to thank those people and them
that's it thank you
thank you councillor casten
okay um
counselor melon
thank you chair um
i suspect like many many of the members
across this house i don't consider
myself a financial expert
but
reading through this report i'm struck
by a couple of things
and one is the paragraph 4.8
where we're told about the the changes
in the rules for lot for lending from
the public works loan board
and we've been very much dependent on
that we've we've borrowed money from
that
we've invested it
and the government thinks so much of
what we've done that they've changed the
rules so that we can't do that anymore
so
what we need to think about with these
investments is that
whether an investment yields over the
short term is one thing
whether that investment is a wise
and a proven thing and a far sighted
thing over the longer term
is a different matter entirely
investing in
fossil fuels
is creating chaos for our children and
grandchildren
so unfortunately i won't be voting in
favor of this report
and the twists and turns of the debate
that has gone on in in audit and
scrutiny audit and standards
and then coming back to cabinet and the
changes in direction
are confusing for everyone but a
decision was made
and then you've chosen to overturn it
i think the original decision was the
wiser one thank you
thank you counselor
before i move back to uh councillor
muller to wrap up
i'd have to say that listening to this
debate i'm struck by the amount of
confusion
uh that exists um and that that that may
be a consequence
of the complexity of the issues that
we have in front of us
however i mean if i read 5.18 i mean it
seems to me pretty clear
you know
it says that the the we're going to
monitor these investments in relation to
esg
and we're going to report on that and if
we need to make changes to the
investment profile
that's what we're going to embark on now
it seems to me counsellors that actually
this is something i've heard before we
have been round this loop in other
council meetings so i i failed to
understand
why we're finding it quite so difficult
um at this particular moment in time
um
having said that
i would also point to the fact that
we are as a council
very financially prudent and responsible
in the way we approach not only the way
we spend money but the way in which we
invest money
and that is
evidenced by the amount of money that
we've invested in cisco and the returns
that the recurring revenue streams that
is providing to this council
it is evidenced by
other investments which are already
beginning to bear fruit i and i can
speak with authority as chairman of
mid-suffolk growth where we're investing
in in in council housing and we're
developing the old headquarters and and
have built fantastic quality homes that
quite frankly have been amazed how
they've just they've actually flown off
the drawing board
right
so
um
not everything we're doing is bad
in fact i think i would say in large
measure a lot of the things we're doing
are very good indeed and we're investing
in gateway 14 that is going to bring
jobs and economic prosperity to this
region and we should applaud that
so
i first one will be voting for this and
i would like to pass the
floor to councilman miller to wrap up
well thank you everyone for your your
sort of comments and questions and thank
you uh thanks for casting for your your
comments etc yes this committee does
work extremely hard but i would also
like to pass on my sincere thanks to
catherine and rebecca and their team for
the incredible work they have done
and i would say like with with an audit
hat on we have had unqualified accounts
for a number of years certainly since
i've been co-chair of the audit
committee and certainly prior to that
which i can assure you from my previous
experience as an auditor
is has not happened very often in the
past not here but in other places i have
ordered in the past so i would like to
pass on my thanks to catherine and wish
her every best of her retirement and
thank you for the hard work and advice
you've given me over the last few years
thank you catherine
[Applause]
thank you chair that vote will now or
should be appearing it is now appearing
in blue if you could cast your vote
thank you
thank you chair the votes are 16 4
15 against and one abstention so that is
carried
that is carried and we will move on to
to introduce this item and to move the
recommendations in the response thank
you
[Applause]
i am pleased to introduce this report
which we discussed at our meeting on the
24th of january
our current five-year external audit
contract was let by public sector audit
appointments following a national
procurement which the council opted to
join in 2016.
the current contract includes the audit
of our 2223 accounts and was led let to
ernst and young along with all the other
councils in suffolk
we now need to decide and let psaa know
by the 11th of march if we again wish to
join the national procurement exercise
to let a further five-year contract and
this decision is a decision that only
council can make
we discussed the three options outlined
in the report along with their
respective risks and benefits which were
to opt in to the psaa option
to make a stand-alone appointment or to
set up a joint auditor panel with local
joint procurement arrangements
we are aware that there have been
national issues with the timely
completion of local authority audits in
the last couple of years
but we supported our section 151
officer's view that this isn't due to
the national contract arrangements and
hence believe that we should continue to
coordinate our efforts through these
arrangements with other councils to
tackle the challenges
the local government association's view
is also that the national procurement
remains the best option for local
authorities
our recommendation therefore to council
is to continue to opt into the psaa
option so i would like to propose the
recommendation i set out in 3.1 and 3.2
of the report i would ask for a second
thank you chair
thank you councilman muller um could i
have a second to please counsel akashan
okay thank you very much mr chairman
happy to second that okay
um are you reserving your right to speak
later
i don't think i will for this one thank
you very much
uh right um it's actually coming up
pretty close to um
8 30
and so i need to um ask uh for an
extension of the guillotine
um
so if you are all happy for us to extend
the time hopefully it wouldn't be for
much longer all those in favor please
show
thank you
thank you very much right well let's
crack on
um
questions
any questions for councillor muller
okay
we'll move to debate anyone wish to kick
off the debate counselor mellon
thank you chair how long have i got
i'm very happy to support the
recommendations thank you
thank you chair i would like to thank
counselor melon for his support thank
you
thank you chair that vote is now showing
in blue if you can cost your votes
yeah
chair so it's um 28 4 and one again
oh 34 sorry with the two um not on the
system so 34 one against thank you okay
okay go ahead
thank you chair
um yeah the the if i could refer back to
last time's minutes
um
one of the answers to the questions was
um to say that the county council are
bringing together a range of
stakeholders from across the districts
to form a poverty board this would help
us to bring resources understanding his
uses etc etc
so my question is
who is going to represent the district
council on the
county-wide poverty board
well i'm not sure councillor morley
oh
i beg your pardon councillor richardson
thank you chair i put my hand up because
i think that was the answer i gave um to
the question that was asked i'll need to
go away and check and provide a formal
uh response outside of the meeting but i
believe it will be an officer forum
rather than a councillor appointed body
thank you councillor richardson
uh councillor mellon
uh yeah thank you chair um
uh i'd like to make a couple of changes
uh to the committee placings from our
opposition group and i understand that
has to be done at the council meeting
and ratified so
um
on the joint audit and standards
committee um
uh council amoroson and councillor warby
warboys will be uh coming off there i
thank them for their their their work on
that
forum and councillor rachel ebern and
councillor austin davis uh will be going
on to that committee
thank you
you